[موسيقى]
علاقه الانسان بصفحه سماء من نجوم وسدم
وكواكب علاقه ازليه فاول ما وجد شاهد سماء
بجمالها وبهائها وحركاتها وسكناتها فظن
انها هي التي تتحكم بمصيره فقدسها ثم عبده
فتولى علم التنجيم فالتنجيم مجموعه من
الاعتقادات حول الاوضاع النسبيه للاجرام
السماويه وعلاقاتها بسلوكيات البشريه
والنفسيه ومعمجي الاسلام ابطل عليهم هذا
ليش لان المنجم بالغ بهذا الى حد الاسفاف
صدق الشرع ولا تركن الى رجل يرصد في الليل
زحل حارت الافكار في حكمه من قد هدانا
سبلنا
عز وجل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والابراج من حيث الحقيقه هي تجمعات نجميه
تخيلها الانسان القديم على شكل بشر
وحيوانات وجمادات وسميت
العلوها تبارك الذي جعل في السماء بروجا
وزيناها للناظرين والسماء ذات البروج
والتفكر بها عباده الذين يذكرون الله
قياما وقعودا وعلى جنوبهم ويتفكرون في خلق
السماوات والارض ربنا ما خلقت هذا باطلا
سبحانك فقنا عذاب النار
[موسيقى]